Let's look at our in order versus out of order quiz solution.
We said already that we have to fetch the code and issue instructions in order.
Dispatching is happening in the order of dependencies not necessarily totally in
program order so this is out of order. Execution then happens out of order.
We broadcast results. When we finish execution out of order.
But then commit has to happen in order, and
then because we commit in order, the rest of the pipeline after commit,
if there is anything will be also in order. So this is what happens in order and
what happens out of order in an out of order processor.
If this were an in order processor, these would also be here.